die deutsche außenministerin vergangene
woche im baltikum der krieg ist hier
ganz nah und die bundesregierung will
putins kriegskasse nicht länger füllen
ich sage daher hier klar und deutlich ja
auch deutschland steigt vollständig aus
russischen energieimporten aus doch das
ist schwieriger als gedacht denn
deutschland hat sich langfristig zu
russischen gasimporten verpflichtet wer
das verstehen will muss nach
ludwigshafen schauen zu basf
einen tag nach kriegsbeginn verkündet
der deutsche chemiekonzern wieder mal
einen milliarden-gewinn
2021 war ein starkes und erfolgreiches
jahr für basf unser ebit vor
sondereinflüssen hat sich im vergleich
zum vorjahr mehr als verdoppelt es
belief sich auf 78 milliarden euro wer
es macht jedes jahr hohe gewinne seit
drei jahrzehnten schon ein wichtiger
grund billiges erdgas aus russland
und das kam so
1990 steigt basf in das lukrative
gasgeschäft ein mit gazprom der
basf-chef erklärt die strategie wir
sehen darin weiterhin die chance im
erdgasgeschäft ein wichtiges
strategisches standbein für wintershall
und basf aufzubauen wir sehr von gazprom
bauen gemeinsam eine eigene pipeline
quer durch deutschland bis zum basf
stammwerk in ludwigshafen jetzt der held
basf günstiges gas aus russland
1994 gründete basf die tochter wingas
der partner wieder gazprom die
gemeinsame mission noch mehr russisches
gas für deutschland
kaum jemand in deutschland will heute
über dieses kapitel der basf geschichte
offen reden thierry bros in paris hat
damit keine probleme er kennt die
gasgeschäfte wie kaum ein anderer und
hat die eu beraten
russland braucht deutsche technik für
seine gasproduktion
basf lieferte diese technik im austausch
bekamen sie billiges gas und konnten
damit extrem günstig produzieren
basf ist äußerst profitabel wegen seiner
günstigen energie
für so viel neues profitables gasreichen
die pipelines nicht aus also baut
gazprom eine neue gasleitung von den
erdgasfeldern in sibirien bis nach
deutschland mit finanzieller
unterstützung von basf
deutschland wollte abhängiger von
russischem gas werden aus zwei gründen
deutschland bekam gas aus russland zu
einem vorzugspreis
das ist auch heute noch so
und deutschland wurde zum europäischen
zentrum für gas
2005 ist billiges gas aus russland einen
standortvorteil und damit chefsache für
bundeskanzler gerhard schröder und
seinen freund den russischen präsidenten
putin unter ihren augen unterzeichnen
die chefs von basf und gazprom neue
verträge für neue pipelines und noch
mehr gas aus russland deutschland
sichert indirekter partnerschaft mit
russland große teile seiner
energieversorgung auf jahrzehnte
daran will schröders nachfolgerin angela
merkel nichts ändern
wir werden die strategische
partnerschaft ausbauen sagt angela
merkel auf russisch
ein jahr später schon unterzeichnen die
chefs von gazprom und basf neue verträge
gasproben darf am deutschen gasgeschäft
mitverdienen und basf kriegt noch mehr
billiges gas direkt von der quelle
[Applaus]
warnungen vor der wachsenden
abhängigkeit von russland gab es genug
das schwedische verteidigungsministerium
dokumentierte schon 2006 dutzende fälle
in denen in russland energie als
politische waffe einsetzte gegen eine
ganze reihe von ländern die studie waren
für den fall einer krise anything can
happen alles kann passieren
warum wurden die warnungen nicht gehört
weder bsf noch sonst jemand aus der
industrie will mit uns vor der kamera
darüber sprechen dann aber meldet sich
ein insider aus der chemieindustrie
er möchte anonym bleiben und schickt uns
ein statement es soll doch bitte jetzt
niemand behaupten dass in der
vergangenheit nicht immer wieder vor
einem möglichen stopp der russischen
gaslieferungen gewarnt worden ist auch
und insbesondere in den betreffenden
fachkreisen geld ist eben stärker als
fakten es hat blind gemacht
und so drückt 2007 außenminister frank
walter steinmeier persönlich den knopf
mit dem gazprom chef aufseher der start
eines neuen russischen gasfeldes und
natürlich ist basf wieder mit dabei
[Applaus]
2008 noch eine gasfeld eröffnung in
russland dieses mal nur die chefs von
gazprom und basf die deutschen haben die
technik die russen das billige gas ein
bombengeschäft
wir werden dort in der zukunft noch mehr
gas aus west gebiet nach deutschland
bringt und für unternehmen bedeutet eine
verstärkung der fachschaft sport
für das viele neue gas dass gazprom und
bsr fördern beide zusammen eine noch
größere pipeline nord stream 1 jetzt
hängt deutschland mitsamt seiner
industrie auf gedeih und verderb an
russischem erdgas
warum hat basf dabei geholfen der
konzern erklärt auf nachfrage
schriftlich
basf hat keine strategie verfolgt die
importabhängigkeit von russischem gas zu
erhöhen und weiter basf hat einen
beitrag dazu geleistet eine für
deutschland und europa wichtige und
wettbewerbsfähige energieversorgung
aufzubauen
als 2014 russland die kim besetzt und
sich einverleibt macht bsf einfach
weiter und überlässt ein jahr später
gazprom wichtige deutsche gasunternehmen
darunter den größten gasspeicher in
deutschland
im gegenzug erhält basf noch mehr
billiges gas neue förderprojekte in
sibirien
unsere projekte sind sehr langfristig
eigentlich geräten oder projekte wie die
nächsten 20 30 jahre die wir jetzt
wieder vereinbart haben heute versucht
deutschland in nur zwei jahren aus
russischen erdgaslieferungen
auszusteigen jetzt rechnen wir damit
dass wir schon im sommer 24 bis auf
wenige anteile uns unabhängig von
russischem gas gemacht haben können das
ist also das ziel der bundesregierung
die russischen gasimporte betrugen 2021
noch 46 milliarden kubikmeter und sollen
bis 2024 stark sinken doch es gibt ein
problem die langfristverträge die
funktionieren nach dem prinzip
bedeutet du musst jedes jahr eine
mindestmenge abnehmen ansonsten musst du
für das gas bezahlen dass du nicht
abgenommen hast
jobs apple's arbeitet beim renommierten
oxford institute für energie studien in
england seinem institut liegen
informationen über die geheimen
langfristverträge russlands mit
deutschland vor exklusiv erhält frontal
einen einblick
die zahlen sähen nicht gut aus so gut
wie alles gas dass deutschland derzeit
aus russland importiert ist dann
langfristverträge mit take or pay
gebunden bis mindestens 2030 40
milliarden kubikmeter pro jahr die
deutschen abnehmer müssen dafür bezahlen
so oder so
denn in deutschland seine russischen
gasimporte unter diesem
mindestabnahmemenge senkt dann muss
deutschland für das gas bezahlen dass es
nicht bezieht
sogar besser gas kommt kriegt geld für
nicht-experten
sie in einen welchen ausweg die
bundesregierung beschließt einen gas
boykott wegen des krieges dann würden
die verträge hinfällig wegen höherer
gewalt doch gegen einen gaswolke läuft
die deutsche industrie sturm allen voran
basf wollen wir sehenden auges unsere
gesamte volkswirtschaft zerstören das
was wir über jahrzehnte hinweg aufgebaut
haben
deutschland steckt tief in putins gas
falle sich daraus zu befreien wird
schmerzhaft und teuer